at the grindhouse honduran coffee sells
for eight dollars
per pound and costa rican coffee sells
for 11.50 per pound if one pound of
central american blend coffee contains
0.4 pounds of costa rican so i did costa
rican in this orange color before so
i'll do it again so it contains 0.4
pounds of costa rican coffee
and
0.6 pounds of honduran coffee i'll do
the honduran coffee in blue
that was our original the first
statement how much should one pound sell
for so they're really just saying well
how much does it cost for me to buy
point four pounds of costa rican and
point six pounds of honduran and if i
take that total that's how how much it's
going to cost me to get one pound of my
central american blend so let's just
figure that out the costa rican coffee
all right here costa
rican coffee
we're gonna it's eight dollars per pound
oh no sorry it's 11.50 per pound we have
to be very careful the costa rican
coffee is 11.50 per pound
11.50
per pound we could write it like this
per
per pound and then we're going to
multiply that times the number of pounds
we want of the costa rican coffee in our
blend and we have 0.4 pounds of it so
times 0.4
pounds the pounds cancel out and you
have 0.4 times 1150
4 times 1150 would be 44 plus 2 which
would be 46 so 0.4 is going to be 4.6 so
this is equal to
4.6
dollars or four dollars and 60 cents now
we'll do the same thing for the honduran
coffee
honduran
honduran coffee we're going to get 0.6
pounds well first let's put the price
here it's eight dollars per pound so it
is eight dollars
eight dollars
per pound and multiply it times the
number of pounds we need point six
pounds of it zero point six
pounds and eight times six is
forty-eight so eight times 0.6 is 4.80
so this is equal to
4.80
so that's how much we're going to have
to spend on costa rican that's how much
we're going to have to spend on honduran
coffee if we add them up that's how much
a pound of the central american blend is
going to cost because we're getting
if you add up the pounds you get a pound
here so the total cost is the total cost
of a pound of the blend
so let's put it right here zero plus
zero is zero six plus eight is fourteen
one plus 4 plus 4 is 9 but the decimal
in the right place is going to cost us a
total of
9.40 for the blend